you
[Music]
I'm happy to welcome Marcus araba from
UC Berkeley here today to give us a talk
about program synthesis and quantify
elimination and qbf and things like that
so Marcus is has been there for a couple
of years and did his thesis in Saarland
University with our minor on hyper LTL
so I'm happy to have you here and so
just what to take away more time please
thanks for the introduction
Yeah right my background is more in
information flow security for methods
temporal logics and so on but recently
I've been more like shifting over to the
synthesis aspect of our formal methods
mostly and my overall goal is to apply
this back into security I think it would
have a tremendous views so well earlier
but previously are some some some years
back we still thought that critical
programming are is Rouladen that some
things like that or this today it looks
more like that these are like like the
scams like that lock your computer and
you can only unlock them for money or
like that where someone hacks into your
car and you end up crashing your car and
so I think there is a shift in in the in
the attention from from the safety
aspects to the security aspects and and
that is I guess mostly driven by the
economic impact which is estimated in
the many billions I mean these are
obviously people who are profitable
profiting from a high estimate here but
I think it's fair to say there is a
really big economic push towards it I
think today might even be the tipping
point for like like people taking
security more serious because today I
think it was the first CEO who had to
step down because of a big data breach
so that might actually change something
I know he's not the first one really at
least super major company as far as I
recall maybe maybe there are more and
I mean they're definitely concerned
about it now yeah okay cool and so all
the while we actually know how to design
secure systems right like they happen
several like major attempts at formally
verifying systems with a very high
standard off of certainty and the SL
microkernel was Mabley
maybe the port that the like the first
really big example is showing that bit
but they are major other efforts in this
area however of course like they still
didn't reach practical or like like the
normal software development because it's
still pretty expensive right so and and
I think that and um for the cost reason
and for others I think that um program
synthesis will have a major impact and I
think of that will be mostly in three
different ways and first of all well the
standard view of program synthesis is
that we can synthesize perform code or
low-level code from higher levels of
abstraction and that would reduce the
complexity in software designs or could
help you and in particular it could
reduce the amount of low-level coding
that's really error-prone now that is
the sort of standard view of problems in
this but I think there are different
ways how to how presenters could be
really used you could Austin designs and
prove objects for theorem provers which
is I think would help to directly lower
the cost of these major verification
efforts and and we could also use that
in automated and program analysis in in
all its variants and synthesize things
like invariance ranking functions and so
on and for by that at least find
vulnerabilities in existing code which
is also very helpful tool of course now
and I see that I considered program
synthesis in a very general fashion here
I think that it typically has this
pattern where we ask well but does exist
some program or some syntactic object of
some class of things that you describe
as that
for all inputs and some specification
holes and typically we can compile these
synthesis problems into such a format
and that it could be also that's exists
approved such that for all possible sums
of the variables it is true assume that
that would kind of represent the you're
improving aspect of it maybe but I think
if we if we managed to solve these
problems in a fairly general and fast
way this could help in many different
ways and would really help for software
for software security so and however of
course I think everyone is aware of that
from synthesis is really not scalable so
far like if if we are really lucky it
scales to five to ten lines of code and
but for that we probably already have to
restrict a problem very much so this is
really a the biggest issue of that
approach yet so the approach that I want
to take is to identify the fundamental
scalability issues behind this and and
for that I want to reduce the the
problem to the simplest form to a very
like pure form where like you can
actually analyze the the problems and
that is I believe the simplest of the
synthesis problem is quantified boolean
formulas will even further restrict it
to just quantified boolean formulas with
one quantify donation just to look at
the core of the problem and that will
study today and for that I will in this
talk suggest a new algorithm and then
we'll evaluate it and and for that we
picked we started out with some
synthesis benchmarks that we're
essentially well synthesizing some proof
objects first and then we'll also took
some benchmarks from from the sketch
benchmark library like that is Commandos
and under helpless and generating
basically women in encodings of his
promising participants and well a reason
why we picked that is well obviously
these were available and we didn't have
to do it ourselves with it is a thing a
good thing for benchmarking because and
that means you cannot cheat and we have
to the files first before we develop the
algorithm and then and the all these
three families included some unsolved
problems and
so
it was possible to measure some progress
towards synthesis there because I don't
believe that we can suddenly scale to
hundreds of lines of code so we didn't
want to set a goal that was too large
now just to be a bit more concrete the
ranking function problem has problems
like that we are given the boolean
program over some say variables and we
basically just ask whether it exists a
constant C and it's such that for all
states X and X Prime if there are
successors so if X prime of X then the
multiplication of at the constant with a
state vector must be smaller than the
well then ended the the product of the
constant with the previous state so a
very simple encoding and that was done
by I cook and some others and they
included problems mostly taken from
Windows device drivers of course were
reduced once but they they had realistic
business so they have their encoding of
16-bit 32-bit and 64-bit and and they
they all like they have small snippets
like that I think this is one of the
smaller snippets and it basically asked
whether it will be given two variables
we only know about them that they that
they are equal on their last five bits
apparently for whatever reason and or or
they're not equal on the last one bit
sorry
and then we are counting the one app and
so apparently someone had had a small
counter in the last five bits encoded
and try to and have a loop over these
okay and it turns out this is a non
terminating program because if index has
it's different to head on on on the on
the bits that it doesn't compare it with
then we store that in the integer I and
here in this comparison it like it will
always fail because we can always carry
we can always count up the last five
bits but it will never do anything so
and and it's sort of as you you can spot
that it's not
that hard but it's not so easy if you
just see a sea of classes and bits and
this is a problem that can be encoded
apparently in some 3000 classes with the
32-bit semantics has some 128 bearable
so you don't want to enumerate things
and yeah in the end it turns out we can
solve these kinds of things but very
quickly within say hundred milliseconds
okay and all right yeah so there's no
ranking much yeah and to prove the
absence is non-trivial it is of course
not a particularly hard for humans but
you want to automatic and it's kind of
it I just want to justify it
oops that we are that this is a
reasonable benchmark for for simple yeah
exactly and the other problems we we
considered word and things like function
summaries of bullying programs and and
programs get this and these were
sometimes substantially larger so the
DVD synthesis we considered were
typically like 50,000 classes sometimes
I'm at a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand classes but I mean this is not
particularly impressive for SMT flowers
or for sad solvers but we are so trying
to solve a harder problem here so that's
kind of I think it's a reasonable
synthesis benchmark if we can do that we
did some progress okay this talk will
have well basically go through this
schedule here and first we will take a
look at the existing synthesis
algorithms on the program level and try
to identify and what what their problems
are and at least one problem I mean they
might and I'm not suggesting here I'm
solving everything and and then we'll do
the step to qbf encodings and we'll take
a look at that and see what the problems
are with qbf algorithms are and then
we'll go into the the algorithm we'll go
through the evaluation and then we have
two parts that are kind of more in
Outlook and there's one theoretical work
on how to lift this through reasoning
about functions and some quantitative
works that also we need
hope we actually make it through the
last part as well well boob it will
depend a bit on the timing all right M
sees this is a very general rhythmic
scheme to solve synthesis queries and
basically we want to just have a very
simple loop or pick a candidate program
will check whether it's the one we're
looking for and if not then we exclude
some programs from the next query and
iterate they are well you can see that
as a learning framework and people have
been exploring the period around that
and we're yeah anyways and we can and
there are two main flavors of that which
is the numerator synthesis approach and
the SMT solver of course maybe there's
also this elastic one that it won't go
into too much today and and they both
come with their problems like the
normative approach is to enumerate
syntactic expressions from small to
large and kind of to always evaluate
them against the count examples you have
found so far and that is you can
enumerate things really quickly but of
course it's clear that once programs get
also once programs get like the prompts
we were looking for get too large then
the number of possibilities just
explodes and we won't get anywhere
unless we restrict the grammars so much
that we that we that that number of
possibilities is kind of small but then
we have to solve to know what we're
looking for so it's kind of not really a
solution in the long run I believe so
the other problem is to use SMT solver
which does not necessarily suffer so
much from this Co monitor Explorer
explosion but it turns out in practice
it does like yeah after we add some sub
queries and SMT solvers like tend to
have read problems at least on the even
colorings I'm not sure whether and there
are much better ones but so far in
literature it seems that and often the
problem is with this we saw was it after
adding a number of counter examples
things really sorta get slow and there
is one problem that both of these
approaches here which is that for some
examples you just need to many counter
examples in particular for there is
where um where we have to refute the
existence offer of an object in a
certain grammar and let's take a look at
this very
put program sketch I sort of think many
people have seen that Armando Sula the
salmon has like promoted that kind of
thing a lot and this is a program
snippet or a small function that this
has one hole in it which is denoted by
these two question marks and the problem
is to find a constant to insert in the
or to trooped by which you want to
replace these two question marks such
that the program doesn't violate its
assertion now I am it's the dysfunction
is we supposed to do something really
stupid really simple just to were
supposed to return a number that is
different to the input right so and
we're given some Y as an input and we
have to then just a constant but that is
a constant that cannot depend on Y and
and then they are supposed to be
different it's clear that such a concert
cannot exist right like for any concert
with Tuesday you can't pick the same
input and it's same but see these
engines really have problems with this
this example they will just enumerate
enumerate and counter examples and each
counter example only excludes a single
constant so that's really that is a
really awkward example for CEA's now M
the way we're gonna encode that in qbf
is that we are unfortunately after
negated this is a bit of a weird point
at this point of the talk and but I
assure you this is only for technical
reasons because we want to work with CNF
so if we and if we work one want to
encode our constraints in CNF there must
be an external quantifier inside and I
assure you this is on one of the only
points where this is a really technical
weird argument in this talk and so we
negate our problem instead of asking
whether the existing program that works
for all inputs we're gonna and ask the
question whether for all programs there
exists account example it's just
negation of the problem and and then
it's clear that our problem problem from
both could be encoded in qbf like that
we asked whether for all access that
exists to Y such that X equals y holds
I'm sort of
assuming an optimal encoding of of this
program obviously when we work with real
encodings of programs there will be a
lot more clutter around this but it's
sort of clear that this is the core of
the problem all right and if you find a
school and function for that GBF that
means we prove that you have to be true
we have refuted the original problem
then for every and for every acts we
found the Y that satisfies the equation
which would then violate the assertion
all right all right now how do m qf
algorithms of that and and and for qbf
so far or at least until recently there
were the predominant algorithmic
approach was the Seeger approach and
which for two qbf can be said really
simple we just take two sat solvers one
for the universal variables one for the
extension variables and we first asked
the one for the universal variables
whether the existing assignment to X
then it gives us some assignment which
it has so far no constraints and we find
then a matching assignment for Y which
is an assignment that for that
particular ax satisfies the formula and
then we exclude all the access like all
the universal assignments that for which
this Y is a solution in this particular
example we had on the previous slide to
the equality constraints this is exactly
one is a universal assignment I can say
oops hey first of all this is pretty
this is basically the same as C it's
just you know like formylated in the
other way round sort of indicated form
and and for for our example in previous
slide is clear that we just exclude one
assignment and that is this leads to
enumerate thing all assignments also
inside and it turns out that even the
competitive qvf solvers and from the
last couple years that are based on this
principle just die virgin that example
that practically never come back if you
have two numerator two to the 32
assignments and that's that this is only
true if you don't consider
pre-processing there are pre processors
that can solve that but you don't sort
of don't want to rely too much on
pre-processing here as soon as something
like that equation hits our solvers
they're done so it's the the problem we
see with CS and for synthesis tools does
exist in the same way for qbf
so it this is sort of another
justification why it makes sense to
actually study the problem in this low
level because we really have to solve
this quantifier problem and to make
progress now now I want to take a step
and just say let's do something
completing you let's let's take it I
mean completely fresh beyond this and
and consider like and we so assume we're
given a two qvf for all X system washes
at the formula finals and and we let's
consider that as a relation between
assignments of two acts and recite
assignments to Y right like the relation
and any pair of assignment to x and y
either is satisfied by the fire or not
and this gives us a relation implicitly
defined already symbolically defined now
we have and what we want to have in the
end is a Coulomb function which is
nothing but a functional and complete
relation right so we are we sort of
taught to talked already about the same
kind of object you just need some
additional properties we need need to we
need in the end to refute order to prove
such a formula we need to find a
relation that is just this has these
additional properties I know
M so let's take this this general likely
relation view and and I look at what
what C or D see your algorithm is doing
and so this is the assignment yeah the
duration here is basically well a set of
arrows between assignments to x and x to
y and now there are two cases that could
make a relation not complete or not
functional like like either there is an
assignment to ax that doesn't have a
matching assignment on the other side
and this is sort of the assignment that
all these CER algorithms are looking for
the kind of browse through the
assignments here and always try to find
something on the other side that matches
it and if they find something that
doesn't it doesn't like doesn't have
matching partner they're done they find
it from the counter example and at some
point they otherwise exclude like the
exhaust the the space of time it's a
universal then they're done now and
we're gonna now focus on the other case
namely the one that the relation might
not be functional
yes you it only has to be total doesn't
have to be functional right now a
non-functional proof is overkill so to
speak it gives more than one example
that refutes every program but
nonetheless you don't require to have
this relation functional and true and we
could also prove it with non functional
that's that's a good point yet we could
prove it with non functional as well and
the typical view how we want to prove it
however is that that's : function right
and a school function is a functional
thing way to the function 1 M now true
true that is also a good point there the
point however why 1/2 the functionality
is that if we that with that property we
can kind of turn this problem around in
and check for the completeness like if
we have a functional relation we can
turn the problem around and check for
the completeness of the relation with a
sense over and then we can come for
asked but is it an input to that
relation that creates a conflict and
that will help to yeah but but I agree
yeah and we could we can also try to not
generate its current functions but
relations
they can't they constrain the they
constrain the x-trail functions
straight yeah function constraints the
yeah the teacher yep
all right we're gonna exploit that
functionality however and and this is
and it comes really handy that it's a
great formulated as calling functions
and on fire relations okay now what
we're going to do is to take our general
relation and add new constraints until
it becomes functional so we won't kind
of collapse these pairs where it's not
clear where to give like what the
matching partner is and on the way we'll
check whether we can Oh file it at this
completeness constraint now the question
of course is what constraints to add and
here we're gonna take CDCl style
approach we make we're gonna add simple
things that are not necessarily correct
we're gonna propagate and check whether
we did mistakes and if so then we learn
from that
well actually learn classes like in CCL
now I think it's kind of best suit along
this example I'm it's CNF I'm and I'm
aware that people are not fluent in to
yet CNF necessarily but I gonna lead you
to it and it's going to be really simple
so we have two universal variables x1 x2
and for extensions and let's for now
zoom in on the first three classes and
mmm these three classes are all have a
particular property there's just one
essential variable in there
the others are universal so we can read
them as implications right can the gate
the left side and read massive Lakai
shion's now then it's clear that we this
least three classes describe three sort
of function cases or cases of a function
and and it says like if both universes
are true then Y has to be true and
otherwise it has before so this is an
and basically not you know I'm drawing
the circuit on the right side just for
distillation purposes just what the
current state of the function is that we
learned so here we just learn okay with
this one variable has a
like a flea if this whole problem has
gone function then this parable
necessarily has to be the end of the
these two universal now and we can do
the same thing with the second group of
variables and however now awaiting now
and we have these classes where they're
two extensions however for the essential
y1 we already noticed : function so it's
sort of okay to replace it by its
cooling function and just let Y to
depend on the outcome of this school
function of Y one so we can learn here
okay this is just the or of x2 and the
outcome of this good question by what
right and so this is a propagation step
that happened by learning that why one
has a particular school function listen
this enables us to learn that y2 must
have had another schoolmaster and then
we could only do that by like like after
learning school function for y1 because
otherwise we would have these classes by
one all right to that and don't have a
particular direction to it to them right
now it seemed we have some more concepts
we might not always be like that they're
lucky to drive all the school functions
and and at least two classes year four
by three they don't they mean they also
have the property that y1 and y2 they
have : functions and there's only way
three and there is it doesn't have a
school function
but these two classes they don't
necessarily determine why three for all
possible signs right I mean there's it
doesn't know it's not functional at this
point right so let's just add a class
just decide for something and we'll
later take a look at what exactly
exactly want it how decisions would look
like it's just add a single class that
says like if Y y1 and y2 so if these two
clauses are satisfied by y1 and y2 that
is if the true and then y 3 should be
true all right now this together he
finds an and
what's fine we just guessed it so we
mark it blue so this depends on the
decision now we try to continue
propagating look at y4 and we find out
that that leads to a conflict a conflict
is that we find an assignment for x1 and
x2 for the universal
volts that propagates through so Phi 1 X
1 X 2 insert them here we get Y 1 y 1
implies y 2 y not whether y 1 and y 2
and pi y 3 and now we have this conflict
that says if y 1 is true then yy4 has to
be true if y 3 is true then why 4 has to
be true and what 4 has to be false and
what cannot be true and false at the
same time so a conflict now and we have
to find this with a sceptic and that we
can but yeah we have to find this
Universal Time with the subject maybe
but that's fine and and now we can go
back we we do confident others like in a
satsang in your class like like this now
it actually turns out that now if y1 is
false and y 3 has to be false and if y 1
is true then y 3 has to be false - so
basically means like y3 is 255 - it
constant false here that's fine we
learned that through the conflict clause
and we can propagate that and it turns
out this works then there's we can just
complete the other thing that's fine so
what we did is now we learned it's
cooling function there has three
distinct inputs what we only needed and
one particular like we only did one
subject to find this one conflict so we
made some some magic happened it's
called like a Seeger approach would have
taken at least three circles like three
iterations and many general that that
that I could have been like much more
stuff around it that we just derived and
that wouldn't have taken any additional
set calls so really did something new
here I think and I would I would say
that we this algorithm exploits the
functional dependencies among the
variables that are there in there in the
in the CNF to define the school of
functions that are uniquely there and
thereby we avoid the enumeration of the
inputs so what I think this
and the topology also the ordering among
variables is derived on the Flies like
there's no predetermined order is that a
question mark does it answer the
question so what while then we're pretty
much screwed
and that usually doesn't happen the most
of the like in particular for it like
Titan encoded for whatever problems
sauce typically have two or three
barrels or four or five sometimes like
you okay I'm okay so I think the best
way to see this algorithm is that we
lift at the CDCl algorithm from sad to
the function space instead of
propagating values you're probably
getting functions or rather we're
propagating the property that certain
variables have unique functions but so
this light also can sort of like chose
like like how would others should be
probably implemented and the state of a
Sat solver is essentially a partial
assignment of the variables a mapping
from variables to boolean values were to
an undefined value in qvf so in the
cubic algorithm we will have an
impartial silent from essential
variables only the extensions to either
skolem function or an undefined value
and the schooling function will just be
described by a set of constraints we
won't have to represent them in any
other way that they are we just we just
identify certain groups of constraints
that we know represent functions then
decisions will be essentially and
constraints or adding constraints
instead of adding a single literal and
conflicts work a little bit different
that we can't use unit propagation only
we actually need a set call to find
conflicts instead of just propagating
the existing part assignment and getting
a conflicting example why not why we
have to ask the SATs over whether they
exist in the time
or input to the functions we have
already such that we propagate why not
why so that it's kind of a major gap
between these two worlds and and but
learning will then be remarkably similar
also learning classes and what is I
think most important and this is where I
think people don't believe me at first
when I talk about it is we need this
notion of propagation and set suppose
would be completely useless without unit
propagation right so we need this
discovery of new things officer of of
unique parts of the solution and end and
so so that is the thing that I think is
really novel thing if one thing of this
work survives a longer time then then it
will be this propagation of this this
property that we and that certain
variables need to have unique schooling
functions and let's find that roughly at
least and so to define unique sculpin so
we first need to define what it means
that a class has a direction we call it
class has a unique consequence and
assume we are given a boolean for a
quantified wound formula and a set of
variables D that already has unique
school and function whatever that means
and and then a class is said to have
unique consequence so unique consequence
LM the last literal here I mean there
cannot reorder them otherwise and if
this variable is not yet in D is an
extension variable but it's not in D and
all the other literals in that net loss
already have either Scala function or
they are universal so in other words if
you want to express the natural language
this like a class is a unique
consequence l if l is the only essential
variable in it that and does not yet
have a school and function it's sort of
like the unit and the unit class a
property where all the when when all the
the Bourbon all but one
literals are assigned we can propagate
the last one and in this case they are
not necessarily assigned but they just
to have a school in function and we know
that this loss has direction okay
yeah unique school on forever but then
has any school in function or this
property holds it we say it must hold
that for all possible assignments to the
universal and all the unique assignments
to the variables in D right there they
all have functions that are so they are
they're all determined in the universal
variables so for any time to acts this
unique assignment you need is tangent to
the variables in D that is determined by
the classes curly D that already that
that to find this color punches and um
such that they exist exist exactly one
value for this pair would be that if
there's case then B has a unique school
function
and this unique value must be determined
only by the classes with unique
consequence like only those that we have
identified to have a sort direction then
we know that this is an approximation of
what it means that there is a unique
school and function we only take in to
counter these unique consequence classes
not the other ones and not many that
could be even whole groups of variables
and classes that only have one unique
assignment or something but we don't
find that so this is a approximation
only takes encounter really local
situation but sufficient to find unique
school and functions in many cases and
furthermore this can be checked with two
simple set checks I mean as expected we
checked with it the relation is locally
functional or whether it's locally
conflicted this just means these are the
d other and the variables is this
quality of the variables s or D they are
the classes that only contain Universal
variables and we're was in D so these
are our schooling function definitions
and those that we've derived already and
then we are asked basically whether the
conjunction of all the of all the
antecedents of the universal unique
consequences and can be satisfied this
means that there exists an assignment
which for which no unique value for V is
determined question
the following way so the clothes gives
either door about interoperable
so Davis Papa will give you the full
operand or power so that these gives you
they the range of values as a function
of other variables and then unique this
is whether the and or subtract this is
this is the view we'll get to in a
couple of slides yeah this is another
way I have two binding yeah until we
find out that it's actually the Casey
yeah and two and conflict will be the
same or a similar similar we just have
to ask whether they're kind of opposing
assignments to I mean we don't have to
go through these exact formulas it's
sort of clear that we can't formulate
these small set queries that only go
over the neighborhood here and they also
asked the the global situation now we
can approximate these oh no I think of
taking this out of the presentation but
anyways we can approximate these two
texts by just dropping the these cool
function definitions and this gives them
the the purely local picture or what
only happens with a group with the
classes that there's predictive
variables involved in and then and we
get an like two different approximations
like we we get an under prop summation
of what means that where was functional
and an over approximation of what it
means it is conflicted but again we can
use that to speed up the algorithm
anyways this is just a principle of
unity now let's take a an abstract for
unit again and let's assume we have some
group of Perak what's like before access
our Universal wise our extension these
are set of variables for which we have a
unique skolem function so this is kind
of a blue circle this kind of includes
all these arrows which are which stand
for subclasses and um that uniquely
define the functions for one two and
three
now the unique consequence are those two
the kind of
leave that that area and we might have a
class like y3 or not buy for y3 is it
variable with uni it would be with a
unique skolem function so we see that
this is this class must be a unique
consequence or must have unique
consequence now this is a class that
actually should involve this should be
multi-edge should include y1 y2 and Y
for sure and this is unique consequence
because I wonder what you are already
determined all right now exactly we'll
we'll go to this sort of partial
function you open an approximation each
of these classes with unique consequence
define a case of this function
definition right this class goes in this
top line it says y 4 has to be defined
as true if not y1 and aqua chills and
then the other two classes defined cases
in which it the varible has to be
default and then we have this unknown
area between it could be more cases that
we don't Reno and and the two checks
that we do the functionality and the
conflict and and essentially to ask
whether this question mark area TBB this
little area is empty this if so then
it's functional and and we can ask
whether there's maybe a conflict which
means that the 0 in the one area
overlap sure I'm a decision now will be
to assign this gray area the middle area
to either the true side of the forest
area we could also take more elaborate
decisions but it turns out the very
stupid decisions are often fine because
if we fail we learn in new classes and
we'll get new entries in this function
table right now yeah let's assume y4 is
true as or is dysfunctional sorry and
it's not conflicted so we can propagate
it what happens is that well we included
in the set D the algorithm propagates
the D gets extended and these are not
unique consequences anymore but others
might others will be then and then we
can maybe propagate more all right I
mean that's pretty straightforward
support now country config another say
what happens if something goes wrong and
we run to conflict when you take some
wrong decisions and so on
let's go sort of back to our previous
example we have had our yeah all classes
and variables here and we had the
conflict for variable Y for which was
provoked only if we have this assignment
X 1 and X 2 because then this class
propagates this thoroughly at the school
gates this is nothing else but a
conflict graph now what's got
implication Rafa sorry implication graph
in sat solvers where we have now just
two types of decisions we have Universal
variables which are here marked in black
and we have these these blue variables
which are decision really essential
decision rules where we just added a
clause right because the conflict could
only be provoked by or what was only
introduced because we added our wrong
decision right and this the wrong
decision is represented by these two
blue arrows and y3 being true all right
so what do we do we go back in this
implication graph learning clause in
this case and not white one or not white
3 and this is what we learned okay I
think I miss the implication step add
the animation step here so yeah so we
learn a class at it and continue and
this key is authorized to the complexity
of this algorithm is the next base
algorithm like cdcl and because in the
worst case we have to add all classes
right particularly the case that all
variables are creating all classes we we
can we get like really big closets right
really a lot of losses in the end all
right and cool so we can actually go
ready to the emulation now I want to get
back to the part like if that's almost
like your sickly delete them or yeah we
can't you can't I mean as long as you
eventually allow to learn out really
many yes
you can trade restarts these are things
I won't show here but yeah my algorithm
does two restarts and and at the
implementation as restarts and also
experimented with deleting classes even
though that curtly doesn't help so much
pretty much because the rate at which it
learns classes is a hundred times slower
than inside Silver's and so I never
collect that many classes that it's
really an issue though that might change
so it's not yeah okay we're going to
take a look at the benchmarks that we
have to find earlier ranking functions
function summaries and program sketches
then we'll take a look at the QB of eval
evaluation unfortunetely I have only the
2016 results not a the updated results
I'll talk a bit about that and then
about certification now ranking
functions and so it will think UF
algorithms is a bit hairy so but we all
will walk through that and we see solid
lines and dashed lines dashed lines are
those that use pre-processing and solid
lines are those that don't use
previously the reason why don't see many
solid lines is that without
pre-processing these algorithms cannot
solve basically any of the benchmarks
right this is pretty sad we see that one
red line which is deputy f5 because it
kind of uses in processing and it
couldn't deactivate that and then would
so it does so it uses the the
pre-processing techniques just like
while it's running and therefore sort of
at least solve some of them and if you
use the the full preprocessor it can
solve basically everything and this is
why all these lines are pretty much is
saying am but like as soon as the
preprocessor stops MV the algorithm
still cannot solve much and this
benchmark and it's a bit hard to see
these I think these algorithms can solve
all but two or three of these benchmarks
and however carrot which is our
implementation of incremental
organization the algorithm which is
presented and can solve all of them and
it can typically solve it a factor of
two to five faster or something like
it's per typically in the order of like
twenty milliseconds like
maybe sometimes up 200 here I think the
worst case was a couple of seconds and
these were benchmarks that included
64-bit encodings of small programs well
it's kind of reasonable and it's already
pretty nice of course you're the
preprocessor the preprocessor because
it's kind of like the standardized are
like it professor everyone uses could
use pretty much every a quick resolve
pretty much everything and therefore I
mean it's it's it's not maybe not the
most interesting measurement yet and now
this is a different match mark the
function summaries and where it looks
already a bit different and again
there's line to present there there's
almost with preprocessor the other ones
without again without pre-processing the
the album scans of anything with
pre-processing it sort of gets somewhere
and the preprocessor was sort of solving
things until that point or that one I
don't know and now there we have some
other lines straight through it and it
ever won't won't go too much of the
details here what we see is that again
carrot and our implementation is like a
factor off when this time like ten to
twenty times faster on the average
instances and console solve everything
here that's pretty cool and even like
really solve these were actually
interesting like the computation of
function summary so it's country
actually a nice verification effort and
for the synthesis and benchmarks we
couldn't solve everything
it doesn't quite continue like that and
also the gap was a smaller
I mean sometimes for some time barons
and other saw was reading better and but
it turns out that with like a 600 second
time it
we were good solved pretty much I kind
of cut off the graph here because there
were a lot of really boring instances
and and then only I think they last like
like twenty or forty
we're really interesting and so already
see like this this this new solver get
somewhere now I want to add to this
comparison is again really like it's
it's hard to compare these algorithms
because all the algorithms are not super
clean implementations of just one thing
but they kind of try to do some tricks
here and there like as all solvers
typically do and so for example you know
in our carrot implementation and I also
implemented and that when it sees that
it can just enumerate a certain thing
and it's reasonably small with some
arbitrarily chosen
cut-offs
it will do that I mean it's only
interest is to solve the thing it's not
only a clean implementation of the
incremental position even though that is
the main thing that happens for most of
the instances it's sometimes also I just
want to add a word of warning here this
is it's not 100% clean and need of the
algorithms are clean implementations of
anything and I would say I know it's a
bit of an maybe I'm a bit too harsh here
and yes and so the key of evil to the 16
look like that which is pretty cool
Khalid is pretty strong here and it's a
to Kiev track only and however for the
2017 benchmark had time to generate this
graph there carried only one the second
price because there was another soul but
that came into the race that is solved
like like I think like for instance is
more or something like really hard em
but where the other servers are still
kind of far off and this new solver is
basically doing a Greek reconstructing a
circuit representation from the CNF and
tries to do seeger on top of that and
that apparently solves also think oh
it's like I'm not exactly where aware
what this guys doing
and we'll look into that so they they
still I mean still some competition
going on I would say between the two
approaches yes I don't want to say see
or is bad just there seems to be some
decent progress happening yeah look
peepers yeah yeah ghost you last year it
was still pretty off for all the other
service it won competitions in some
earlier instances like you see the
yellow line is this one but apparently
he implemented some new circuit
detection that is way better than the
earlier one and could solve more I don't
know what the exact advantage is
exacting that is he that he knew trained
he proved this thing I know all right um
all right I think we can you can see
that the
this this view I could and so this new
algorithm actually helps us to solve
more instances like interesting
verification benchmarks and it's not
rely it doesn't rely on enumerate again
puts it often really fast on like
average insulin or easy instances and it
doesn't require pre-processing right
like an cat I've never used any kind of
pre-processing which is really important
if you want to create a proof over the
over the over the formula and and and so
um and then that gives rise to this
picture which is a bit show-off maybe
too much
I know here collected set instances from
all these benchmarks and Randy ran the
only two folders that are able to
certify actually there's a third one
that is also due to me and a colleague
and but that's pretty much the same as
bacteria and and I measured for the
different instances the sizes of the
certificates now and not only can
carrots whole way more it can also like
also certificates are just like many
orders of magnitude smaller I mean
that's not resupplies
and because there are certificates it
looked like that which is just this is
probably an adder or something or plus
one I don't exactly know an increment
maybe and and and all these I mean these
lower triangles or universal variables
is upper our essential variables or I
think also the nodes or essential
variables and and enumerate thing all
the assignments for this thing is just I
mean just takes way too long and and
there qbf couldn't couldn't use many of
these optimizations you have to
deactivate many optimizations to be able
to certify and cannot use pre-processing
right now there are some efforts to
re-enable pre-processing and kind of
carry through these these certificates
it's still a bit hairy and didn't really
work and to me and so it's not not
surprising that that could be F really
like the number of gates and this thing
reaches up it just does a huge case
attention over everything is really not
effective and kettering the other hand
can basically propagate these these
structure so I it didn't invent this
structure it was just in the instance it
just propagated it
so what's fine it means we didn't do
much work
it has spread the definitions that are
in the problem alright so and it's
spoofs out these sorry you see there
some weird things happening below here
we were there so it probably added some
weird classes there learn some new
classes and then it returned that it
okay now okay to summarize this first
part okay or we are already permitted
the end and we we have seen that this
algorithm like we've seen this
definition of propagation particular
flynny consequence and unique school of
functions the partial function we how
confident others works roughly and what
why it's terminating eventually
numerators all the classes and we have
seen tabulation but it's not seen is all
the details likely how it's exactly
implemented it's pretty close to sat
solver when it when I sit down
implementing it it's really not that big
much of a difference just that you need
to have like this extra Sat solver
inside that kind of generates a conflict
and so on and there's other notions that
that really helps us be things that like
pure literals restarts basic heuristic
and so on these are all implemented in
there in the solver
okay now I want a last couple of minutes
I want to at least add one new note and
one one interesting note and this
algorithm can I think that what one view
is one one view algorithm is that it can
really symbolically compute functions
its calling functions only only for two
PBF right now and and the question is
whether we could maybe extend it to
compute not only Scala functions but
general functions the difference is that
for two qvf scoring functions all at the
same domain
why didn't we if we might want to
introduce functions that have different
domains you might want to actually work
with the logic that and can introduce
essentially quantified variables at
functions that have different domain
interesting and then if you have a sort
of qbf here that can use the function
applications inside there is a logic
called DQ BF they can pretty much do
that it's also similar to EPR if you if
you do some coding tricks so that would
be that would be super interesting and I
think in particular for verification
purposes it will be amazing to have
have a symbolic algorithm without that
we can't treat these functions in a
symbolic way because we can represent
the whole memory state or the whole
state of a system by that by function we
can even represent the whole execution
symbolically which is just here these
are mapping addresses to bytes right and
we can represent data structures and
arrays strings map and so on with with
functions so punch is a really natural
way how to formulate problems how to
think about it also we humans would
never enumerate the inputs of a function
which kind of think about them
symbolically also our proof of place
like ranks and rank functions or
invariants are I mean naturally
expressed as functions name many of
these like many of these things I've
been talking about are currently
addressed by specialized algorithms for
example in SMT solvers and more and also
in elsewhere like theories like UF
arrays and so on
and however often they tend to represent
these functions as function tables by
which I mean that they sort of introduce
one variable for every possible input at
least for the inputs they need to
consider and so they kind of expand it
into a more a flat problem and solve it
there that's surprisingly effective I
mean they ask me a lot of work it's
pretty good but I think we could maybe
and we I mean if we could maybe am
coming with the symbolic algorithm that
at least helps in the case for these
other algorithms explode now the
question for us is how could we possibly
argue symbolically where these functions
and I've not seen another where we have
algorithms may be in the first all are
improving world but also there I'm not
sure I'm happy to hear about your
opinions on that but yeah you seem to
have a yeah I try to matter so far he
hasn't convinced me oh yes okay okay
people I'll try to get more out of him
and um anyways let me present what what
I think this video and and for the
and I've been looking at investigating
how we could possibly reason about these
functions and there's one major problem
and and that is that resolution does not
seem to work or this doesn't seem to cut
it for it for D G B F so a CDC else out
solver for dqf is not just just
impossible because
cdcl just just does strictly resolution
in the end now for sat and qvf
resolution just cancel value you can
solve setting qbf by resolution but just
building all result resolved ins in
principle and if you derive the empty
class or closet a corner contains
universals you're done for d qf the
exist an example youtube by the benefit
that and shows that this is not possible
DQ f now presume we have this logic that
allows these function applications in
classes just treat them as atoms per
night and and and then there is this
formula which is introduced this one
function that map's bit like bits to
bits single bits so single bits and and
and then the formula says like whenever
x1 and x2 are true then F of x1 should
be the same as f of x2 I mean the One
Direction is easy to be fine but the
other edges actually doesn't seem to be
I mean it's like and it's clear that
such a function cannot exist there's too
many assignments for which which these
are the three assignments of 2 X 1 X 2
where they're not the same but f of X 1
FX 2 cannot be consistently defined to
satisfy the quality and you can try it
out in your hand it's really just a
small combinational problem and and it
turns out that even if you now try to
build more resolve enforce for this C of
classes and all the resolve ins are
either trivially true or they are
already contained in this set of classes
so we cannot derive a new class but the
formulas fall so resolution doesn't cut
it here now and the India and and all
the complete algorithms dqp have so far
essentially also in the end up and have
to do solve it only by extending the
expanding the function tables yeah
reduction the injection of who takes
first possible is explained by C well
you could try to insert like like
concrete values yeah but then you end up
in numerating values yeah because why do
you literally cannot derive a new path
to resolution in this I mean you just
take say the first two so you have
Universal quantifiers in each
distribution but but they are I mean you
don't confess there that are they
globally right I mean I know that in in
for first of the theorem provers state
you kind of try to keep quantification
locally and you try to unify classes and
so on you can do that that I wouldn't
works yeah and um however in practical
valuations it seems that these souls are
absolutely not even competitive with the
new visitors and numerating things in in
in in the qbf competitions we had an
submission from the like from an EPR
solver that converted QB after he PR and
couldn't solve basically anything yeah
right because the encodings that we were
interested in have 10,000 50,000 losses
this is not really the realm of these
but I mean I'm I agree that there is it
I I don't want to dismiss their work and
I mean resolution I mean this is
literally approved but in their work and
it's really I mean and also I checked it
myself to really go through this thing
and you can take any two classes though
they were there resolving and it's
either trivially true that means it
contains like opposing literals or it is
already contained in that thing I mean
the first two ones for example if you
resolve them with a pivot F of x1 is
trivially true because then you have
every x2 and not every student
okay I'm not gonna I mean the Arctic
need to soften but not through
resolution yeah so you think you can't
solve this problem just treating half of
X 1 and f of X 2 yep that's propositions
yeah if you want to replace them and in
zhanchi 8 them yes you can then it can
solve it but then you are in the realm
of a numerating values okay cool yeah I
would be very interested in that
actually yes so we kind of done then
from the opponent took a different route
than than than in sentation definitely
and and we introduced a simple proof
system for DQ bf and that avoids that I
mean I know we're kind of short on time
so I'm gonna make this fast
and for that we to talk about this
briefly we have to introduce the the
actual notation of Nikki F which doesn't
usually come with functions typically
it's formylated in terms of hanging
quantifiers which to think that we say
exists a function f that has these
inputs where these are always Universal
variables and and then you can use that
F which actually solve a function
application of F to these arguments
inside that formula now this is sort of
just a normal function where every
function just has one set of inputs and
actually it turns out we proved in and
maybe that we can just rewrite that in a
linear with a linear blow up that we use
or you can rewrite these this
qualification of a function in with
linear blow up into that hanging
qualifier representation pretty easy and
so we now just have formulas like that
we say like okay we have some symbol y1
that depends on the inputs x1 we have
some simple x2 that depends on X 2 and
let's just zoom into one class x1 or x2
the question that is really important to
ask you or that really help to help make
you understand this is who is
responsible for satisfying that loss if
we rinse at that is if x1 and x2 are
empty so they're both propositional
variables one of them statically
satisfies it also has to find for any
solution that's clear otherwise it would
be violated for qbf and we know that
either x1 includes X 2 or X 2 includes
x1 probably because x2 is accursed
behind
x1 in the in the quantifier prefix it
includes maybe more Universal variables
and not the other one and then and we
can say whenever they cost not certified
by y1 y2 has a satisfied and it can and
you can know because it knows more
universal variables anyways then now we
can indicate if we don't have the
property we these could be incomparable
could have x1 x2 could be just like
neither and like neither one includes b1
no they not not the other way around
ok in this case and the basic inside was
that y1 y2 have to coordinate based on
their shared information and so only on
the values based only on the values of
the data that occurred both next one
next to it has to be clear which side
satisfies the clause and this gives rise
to our proof rule which essentially says
given a class with two parts just two
separate parts and that that where the
one part cannot depend on the on the
dependencies of the one other part and
and the other way around so they have
incomparable dependencies and then we
can induce a fresh variable T that it
just depends on the intersection of the
two dependencies and this variable T
controls which side of the class has to
satisfy the origin clause to introduce a
new function that resolves this thing we
kind of repeat we call these classes
information forks sort of in its kind of
they're similar term in an LTL so does
this work of distributed systems and
because it's all sort of the same thank
you and then we just need the two
standard rules for proving GBF owners
resolution and universal reduction you
know stretching the sense if we have a
class full of universal we can drop them
all create the empty class and now in an
example I can work this this is just a
previous example with the without with
our functions just that now the
functions are called I mean with this
equality of the functions we
if x1 inuksuit holes just that now that
f1 and f2 are unfortunately called y1 y2
so what we just do is we split all the
classes because they all have this
property that they have y1 y2 and and we
introduce this variable to t 1 to t 6
which are positive integers positively
or negatively here and they all have
anti dependencies because the
intersection of set of x1 x2 or empty
and and then we just apply resolution we
get a form that only over the variables
T we apply more resolution n equal to N
and our I get the empty class and are
done we have proven it to be false so
this this works and we have a proof that
it it makes resolution complete I mean
these three rules form of complete
proofs is ridiculous and we can solve in
a very symbolic way I would say yeah
formulas that we quantify over functions
pretty cool and so far no implementation
exists so it's really hard to say
whether it's going somewhere by hand we
were able to solve some forms by that
that are sort of interesting but of
course that is so far just an exercise
it's really I don't want to claim I know
how to create an efficient solver around
that and but there is a sort of
connection to humans atomization that I
believe is there and I'm still working
on that anyways ok now ok I want to
don't want to go into the last part
because now time is running out it's
anyways a very interesting thing that
quantitative synthesis part we can
approximate synthesis queries with sat
solvers and so really cool thing but
I'll leave that out and we're gonna jump
to the end ok I have presented the
incremental incrementalization algorithm
for two qvf sort of sketch out how this
could be maybe lifted to quantifying
over general functions
boolean functions of course and and and
there is there's more work in this area
that out also happy to have you talk
about and if you're interested I'm here
all day and happy to take questions and
discuss later
quantitative since this is so much worse
I'm the very the very short summary is
mmm okay we solve that problem you're
given some function from exponential
from exponential space of natural
numbers to another expansion special
numbers and and where the function can
be sharp be hard to compute for a single
input we have exponentially many inputs
for each input is a sharpie hard and we
have no convexity assumption no
assumption that all about the this
function and not even that it has any
informative derivatives to send anything
and it's no claim we can given we can
give you find an input that is probably
close to the maximum and that would only
polynomially many calls us at over
that's the it's it's true more okay yeah
true model counting and there's a very
neat trick how we can extend that to
actually turn it into an optimization
algorithm
[Applause]